Let's say we have an array
representing the contents of a bag.
In Objective-C, arrays are not typed.
Instead, every item in
an array is a type ID.
That means we can fill up our bag
with all different kinds of objects,
a bowling ball.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
A lamp.
A string and hey one more lamp.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Now, let's say we want to randomly
grab an item from our bag.
We'll do that by generating
a random number first.
[INAUDIBLE] Now,
at compile time, we don't know what
class our mystery item belongs to.
It's marked with a type ID.
At runtime,
we can get a little more information.
If we throw a log statement in there,
we can see in the console that the class
of our mystery item is a lamp.